ما حسابات كل معسكر معسكر كمال كالشار
اوغلو تحالف الشعب ومعسكر الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان تحالف الجمهور في هذه الجوله
الثانيه
[موسيقى]
الجوله الثانيه ستشهد ربما
انتقالا لاصوات بعض الناخبين
ونجد ان
هو يدافع عن القوميه التقليديه اما
حزب الحركه القوميه يدافع عن القوميه
الثقافيه يعني نجد ان هناك قوميه عنصريه
ان صح التعبير وهناك قوميه ثقافيه
فبالتالي ان نعم سموا انفسهم التحالف
الاجداد نسبه الى جد الاتراك مصطفى كمال
اتاتوركو وبالتالي اظن ان حتى داخل
تحالف الاجداد سيكون هناك
انقسام وفي الجوله الثانيه حسب ما ارى
اليوم ان
اردوغان
يحظى اكثر
بامكانيه الفوز هو خاصه
الناخبين في الاناضول الذين ايدوا ربما
لسبب ما من القوميين بسبب تواجد ربما نعمل
حزب الجيد ربما
سيتوجهون لانهم اقرب الى القوميه الثقافيه
وليسوا اقرب الى القوميه العنصريه الصحه
التعبير
وبالتالي انا لا اظن ان هذا الفارق بين
التحالفين سيتقلص وسيذوب هذا بعيد نوعا ما
ولكن سنرى ان احد الطرفين سيفوز في نهايه
الامر بعد انتقال الاصوات من اوغنوا وربما
من الطرف الاخر الى الاخر ولكن حسب
التوقعات ان
النعم المؤشر والكفه ستكون لصالح اردوغان
بنسبه 50
خاصه ان موضوع الاكراد وموضوع
المنظمه الارهابيه ايضا
نجده هو موضوع مشترك بين
سنان اورانو وبين ايضا تحالف الجمهور نجد
هذا الموجود ثم ايضا نعارات والشعارات
المحافظه
اليمينيه ايضا موجوده في كلا الطرفين طبعا
الرد توفي فعل وتحرك سنان اوغان بالذات هو
مهم نحن نعتبر سنان اوران شخصيه سياسيه
جديده في الساحه السياسيه التركيه
هو ضد الغرب كليا ولديه
تصريحات عنصريه
ومندفعه فبالتالي هو ايضا
يعني نعتقد انه وجه جديد في السياسه
التركيه ربما ربما ايضا
الحاله
الاجتماعيه السياسيه والسوسيولوجيه
الاجتماعيه ستشهد ربما تغيرات جديده في
الحقبه القادمه